as you can see we have a lot of wine
behind us and we're going to try to
drink it all tonight
this is a two thousand ten minute when
the great vintages in Napa Valley in the
north coast the smell all black fruits
black raspberry blackcurrant this one is
rich powerful and a wine I could put
away in my wine cellar for the next 20
years the highest rated wine in my
opinion in Tuscany is brunello di
montalcino it's going to medium and
style good acidity but without acidity a
wine will never age I could smell this
one all day and not even drink it in one
of the great food wines it's ready to
drink when you buy it one of the great
things about the Lassiter of course
being Pixar is the label I guess they
know a little bit about making cartoons
and artwork this wine is a blend of
malbec Cabernet Sauvignon Merlot and a
little bit of Cabernet frog and they've
actually done a great job in blending
these different grapes to make a whole
wine and that's what I'm looking for one
of the great things about wine is it's
made all over the world countries like
Croatia which you might not think of
growing grapes in making wine this is a
unique line a spicy wine and are ready
to drink angelina jolie brad pitt and
wine yes it's true i think that that's
something that people should know about
celebrity ones that they're not really
just giving their name away you better
make sure that there's good quality
because you can't fool
Americans no one I love the color of
Rose a this wine is refreshing and the
most for the best part it's inexpensive
of course the biggest question I always
get asked is which one did you like
better put me on the spot I'm going to
go with our director Francis Ford
Coppola I like his wine I like his
movies Cheers